moving on so I'm sure you've heard of
the whole Jada Smith and yes I've heard
of small things but I don't really know
the full story neither do I I don't
think anyone does I actually saw a meme
the other day um someone sent me a meme
and it was like uh Jada Smith says she's
actually never met Will Smith um which
really tickled me because uh it wouldn't
surprise me if that hit the news the
next day but from what I know that whole
thing happened with Will Smith punched
him Chris Rock and kind of since then I
think all of this stuff has come out
about the relationship a lot of people
on the internet are calling Will Smith a
simp um it does seem like he's really
trying his best to make this
relationship work and she just seems to
be this kind of tyrannical dictator
that's standing above him and just
keeping him very much at a distance um
but yeah we have a video of Jada Smith
in an interview um discussing this
relationship so let's take a look if you
find another great love or If Will finds
another great love there's no finding
another great love and I think that's
the point it's like we are in a place
now that we are in a deep healing space
and we are really concentrating on
healing the relationship between us so
it may not be the divorce on paper
anymore there's no divorce on paper I
mean not on paper there might not be a
divorce in theory anymore yeah no we
really have been working hard oh see
well I didn't know I was trying to well
wait wa totally miss that on the whole
that's the whole thing so wait so wait
just so I'm 100% clear you were divorced
not on paper but now we might be a point
where we're back together we are working
very hard at bringing our relation yes
bringing our relationship together back
to a marriage again back to a life
partnership yes because here's the thing
about husband wife marriage for me for
my healing process I came into that with
very specific ideas very specific ideas
that were blocks to me just seeing will
as who he is he can't be this perfect
idealized husband I have to be able to
accept him for the human that he is he
accepts me for the human that I am and
we want to love each other there okay so
you might like live in the same house
and have the yeah okay poor will and
those poor
kids I just really want to point out how
uh she's all about her and her
expectations of the marriage and it
seems like she's indicating that he fell
short of her expectations um but she
doesn't seem to have any concern for
what his expectations were and maybe not
to be cheated on yeah exactly cuz I
heard she's been around yeah I I think
that's true and it wouldn't really
surprise me just going off of off of
this it wouldn't surprise me if she's
the kind of woman that's been around she
definitely seems like the kind of woman
that is not hair bonded to her partner
so that would suggest that she's been
around the block a few times but I I
really have a problem with people who
air out their dirty laundry I really
really don't like it when people as I
said they air out their dirty laundry
they they put all of their problems in
the public eye um I just think it's bad
taste I think it's tacky it makes me
cringe um and even if someone close to
me did it I would just have to act like
I didn't see it
because I'm not going to get involved on
that I'm not going to jump on the
bandwagon of say a friend post something
about her boyfriend she's slagging him
off or whatever I'm not going to then
jump on that bandwagon and pop up and be
like can't believe he did this cuz
you're just fueling the fire um and
really relationship problems should be
within the relationship it should be the
the couple versus the problem and
especially in a marriage because you
know that's the whole thing the sanctity
of marriage is between two people
and all problems should be resolved
between you two within the context of
that yeah and sometimes when you
actually go to other people and go
against your partner or husband in this
case it can actually have a bad effect
because some people don't have your best
interests at heart and then they can
advise you the wrong things and lead you
to do to make bad decisions and ruin
your marriage so definitely not um the
right way to go about it I mean I agree
with what she's saying about you know
you can't have unrealistic expectations
of your husband and you need to love him
for who he is because you know in a
marriage you're both Sinners you're both
you're not perfect no one's perfect
we're all imperfect so you have to
accept that but you know she hasn't
actually treated her marriage with that
with that same attitude because if
you're if you believe that you shouldn't
be cheating on your partner I don't
understand that like a marriage isn't
for that yeah I mean I think it's all
very hypocritical and I think it's
really important what you said you know
when you take problems outside of the
relationship you you're really running a
real risk because the truth is not
everyone does have your best interests
at heart and I think especially with the
fact that what we're seeing is the the
half of this relationship that is
outsourcing the problems is is the
female Heth and I think it's especially
dangerous in this day and age when women
go to their friends about relationship
problems because the truth is we've
we've seen already with the other topics
on on today's agenda you know a lot of
women out there are messed up right now
they've been fed so much [__] by the
mainstream media by social media and
even with the way that we're raising
kids today a lot of women actually don't
like it when their friend is in a
relationship especially if they're part
of today's culture of things like going
out clubbing and everything's for the
Instagram pictures they don't want their
friends to be in a relationship because
that means oh well I'm I'm I'm not going
to be able to go out and get drunk with
you as much yeah of course they're going
to encourage you to bin off a
relationship because they they don't
actually care about your happiness they
care about what you mean in relation to
them yeah so yeah I think that's a
really Point jealousy exactly as well
they they want it they pretend they
don't want it but they do want it
because they know they can see how happy
you are and they don't seem to
understand that because maybe they've
never had that before yeah so they try
and discourage you from um pursuing
something meaningful yeah um and they
try and make you trade it for something
which is you know less meaningful
definitely because they know that they
can't attain that for themselves but I
know there's a there's a continuation
from this interview so so let's see what
else it has so in the comments we've got
their relationship sounds like a trauma
Bond oh this term this term is driving
me nuts I like to say that trauma Bond
uh is um the excuse that people use for
being with someone who doesn't make them
happy I've never heard of this before so
a trauma bond is this idea that
uh so say you get with a gentleman and
this gentleman starts breaking your
heart maybe you unfortunately go through
some kind of abuse it's not working the
relationship is dysfunctional the idea
of a trauma bond is that the reason you
stay is because psychologically you're
kind of addicted to the stress of it so
it's this whole idea of like chasing the
highs and lows the roller coaster of a
relationship and how you know movies and
everything will tell young girls to go
after the toxic guy because that's where
the roller coaster is yeah um more
exciting yeah but you know and we've
told kids that having a healthy
relationship is boring and that it's
better to have a toxic relationship
because at least then it's thrilling but
yeah I think it's just an excuse trauma
bond is just a way to go I don't like my
circumstances but I'm too addicted to it
to change them I actually used to
believe that myself um but I've woken up
to that as well and I now know that you
can always remove yourself from
something like if you always have that
choice like you're you're in complete
control of your actions and yeah making
excuses isn't going to get you out of
anything and it's just going to make you
more unhappy and yeah don't agree with
that I'm not even denying the psychology
behind it because you know when you look
at things like addiction why do people
get addicted it is because of things
like a release of oxytocin a release of
dopamine and I think when you are in a
toxic relationship that definitely can
be the case that you kind of get maybe
it's similar to addiction maybe it is an
addiction but you can very you can very
much get lost in the ordeal of it all
you can get lost in the roller Coter
addicted to the good parts and you keep
wanting the good parts to come and you
chase the highs yeah no matter how low
the lows are however like you
say whether or not we can always set
ourselves free you know because some
people may argue well what about
cracking KS and heroin addicts you know
I just think it's better to at least
perhaps it's delusional but if you can
tell yourself that no matter what you
can always change your circumstances
chances are you're going to be better
off in life because even when the odds
are completely against you if you have
that mindset of I can always change my
circumstances you're going to try harder
to do that so it's just a a better
mindset to have in general but yeah
another comment says I saw a Tik Tok of
a therapist who dissects how
narcissistic people speak and how they
speak on both sides so that they are
never wrong right or can be caught in a
lie I dismissed the Tik Tok until I saw
this video she is choosing her
words so very delicately so very
delicately yeah I can kind of see that
she just looks a bit Psychopathic I mean
I just think it's you're obviously
chasing something if you have to
constantly go on TV and talk about your
relationship and she she just constantly
seems to be slandering will like it just
seems like all the time she's just
[__] on him and sometimes she
disguises it as she's trying to say oh
we're like this one we we're healing and
we're working together it's like but
don't act like you haven't done all of
these other interviews previously where
you've been making him look like a weak
man like you've really damaged his
reputation but it probably helps her
because then she feels stronger she
feels stronger because you can tell
she's very masculine like
yeah the way that she presents herself
the way that she speaks the way that she
talks even you can tell that she has
full control in that relationship and
he's just like hopelessly in love with
her and like trailing behind her like a
little
dog um and yeah sadly he hasn't realized
that he can break himself free from that
but 100% agree with I do also think that
because of marriage and like the S
sanctity of it I do believe that you
know once you marry someone you've made
that choice
yeah yeah I think will is keeping his
side of the agreement um I I don't know
if Will is a religious man but maybe
that comes into it maybe that's why
probably isn't I mean I don't I think
they're quite the opposite of religious
I think they yeah worship something
[Laughter]
else we we've got to do an episode on
that
because yeah I I agree with you
but look something's keeping him there
whether it be you know the sanctity of
marriage or maybe just pure
embarrassment something's keeping him
around and I can't help but feel bad for
the guy perhaps that's because I'm a
woman so I'm empathetic and emotional
about it I feel bad I'm sure a lot of
guys would sit here and say he needs to
leave her um and I agree but I can't
help but feel bad for him because he's
just like you say trading along like a a
lost puppy another comment says why is
she always speaking in riddles and
avoiding the truth in tanglement working
hard to bring our relationship together
divorced but not divorced I'm tired
honestly she reminds me of
[Laughter]
Boris we're on YouTube so we'll say no
more but if you know what I mean you
know what I mean I know what you mean